if you want to see some real cringe on
this entire Martha's Vineyard and just
generally flying immigrants bussing
immigrants around stun I have video for
you today a Fox News sending listen I
don't know who speaks Spanish at Fox
News like I don't know who they have
that speaks Spanish but one guy that
multiple times have been has been sent
to speak Spanish to migrants is a
reporter named Griff Jenkins that's not
the guy on the screen right now this is
Steve Ducey who's going to cut to Griff
Jenkins it's hard to think of a more
cringy video
throughout the last couple weeks of this
immigrant Martha's Vineyard Washington
DC busing airplane Fiasco then this
video
uh Venezuelan migrants mostly Venezuelan
migrants not all were quote interviewed
by Griff Jenkins and he can barely speak
Spanish he has no idea what they're
saying the migrants can barely
understand his Spanish it almost seems
like a parody take a look at this
from our Southern border have just
arrived outside vice president Kamala
Harris's Residence at the Naval
Observatory in Washington D.C by the way
this is also part of the stunt right
send a bus of migrants right to where
Kamala Harris lives it just this doesn't
help anyone this this is just a stun
Griff Jenkins is live on the scene to
tell us more Griff is that Massachusetts
Avenue that I'm looking at right there
yeah good morning Steve amazing Brian
this bus just arrived moments ago I
talked to some of the folks apparently
this bus has come from Del Rio Texas
that's why the German on the bus told me
and he's part of me they don't the
Harris
so that way if you if you missed what
that was that was the Don Davis de Don
Davis
and even if you speak Spanish it's like
what is he saying what he's trying to
ask is
where are you from that's the question
de Don Davis
sounds more like a Kanye album
English no okay so he asks she says
she's from Venezuela asks if she speaks
English she says no Tina no La PR La
presidenta Harris
this okay
Frontera
serado okay so when he says there
Frontera serado what he means is
the border is closed
um Kamala Harris said the border is
closed now
I don't know whether it's reasonable to
think that Venezuelan migrants who have
been on a bus for a whole bunch of time
and coming through Mexico and all these
things that they would necessarily be up
on the latest declarations from Kamala
Harris so the entire thing is bad faith
but here's the answer
La Frontera is
Serato Roberto
so he asked is the Border open or closed
and she says it's open and this is
supposed to be some kind of gotcha
moment she's saying Steve I asked her
vice president Harris says that the
border is closed she says it's open as
we see these migrants coming across now
we're not sure how many there are we do
know that according to Texas governor
Abbott's office there have been about 7
900 pardon me do you speak English
Venezuela okay so another individual
correctly identifying the Don Davis as
where are you from and says he's from
Venezuela
everybody from todos Venezuela foreign
so Griff asks is everybody on the bus
from Venezuela and the guy says uh yeah
mostly you know it's a really difficult
situation in Venezuela right now
immigration
[Music]
[Music]
so what this gentleman is explaining and
Griff Jenkins has absolutely no idea
what's being said and it actually this
would be the most interesting thing to
translate is yes you know it's been a
really difficult trip we've been
traveling for days they kind of screwed
us in Mexico and we just we want to be
here we want to do things we want to
work I I believe he said
um this would actually be relevant to
translate but of course they're not
actually set up for that
okay thank you yeah buenos your day so
I'm not gonna be able to translate all
that and I wouldn't even try because it
wouldn't look good on live TV but yeah
he has no idea what the guy said as you
can see they're coming across here all
of these migrants it appears to be at
least 20 or so at this point we have two
buses so what I was saying was we know
from Governor Abbott's office there have
been about 7 900 migrants on over 190
buses coming to DC more than 2 200 on
more than 40 buses to New York and of
course about five buses to Chicago with
a little over 300 migrants let's see if
we can get one more interview in Griff
because they're just so good I don't
know the Earth the donde Iris yes
so he says I don't understand English
which is really funny because Griff
appears to be tried to speak Spanish and
this guy's like I don't sorry I don't
speak English I'm in English no no no
okay
now he's talking to a kid
now he starts talking to a kid at which
point I'm gonna cut the interview
um it seems like a parody
it is important to mention if all these
folks are really coming over it kind of
seems to prove Trump didn't really build
the wall right I mean he claims he built
it and yet of course the wall could be
defeated with a hundred dollars in
supplies from a Home Depot as we learn
so no great deterrent if it were built
but it wasn't but Trump claims it was
and yet these folks are still here so
just another one of these pathetic
displays get an actual Spanish-speaking
reporter who can translate you know the
the thing about it is
if you're going to try to communicate in
Spanish
and you're going to struggle that's okay
as long as then you have the ability to
understand and explain what these folks
are saying because the guy there who
told the story of how they came to be in
the U.S traveling for days Mexican
immigration all these different things
if you don't speak Spanish you have no
clue what the guy said and Griff Jenkins
just laughs it off by saying I'm not
going to try to translate all that these
people are pathetic and it's disgusting
let me know what you think find me on
Twitter at dpacman we're going to take a
quick break and be right back
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to hold on bags.com and
you'll save twenty percent with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below